la gran pregunta que nosotros siempre
nos hacemos es que si realmente estamos
preparados para tomar las decisiones
pero sobre todo reflexionar si realmente
estamos preparados para tomar las
decisiones correctas qué es lo que más
nos interesa personalmente me gusta
mucho el cine y hace unos años vi una
película de tom hanks esta película
reflexionaba o traía a colación un hecho
de la vida real
el nombre de la película de su lee y
básicamente esta película relata o
recorre un hecho de la vida real en
donde un capitán en este caso el capitán
sully el piloto comercial de una
aerolínea pues emprende su trabajo como
un día normal y corriente en barca la
tripulación 115 pasajeros de la ciudad
nueva york y despegan sin ningún
problema informan a la torre de control
que han salido han despegado y en
contados segundos
la aeronave tiene un problema de
emergencia ocasionado por la colisión de
un gran número de aeronaves en los
motores en ese momento los motores se
detienen por esta emergencia y
inmediatamente el capitán sully informa
la torre de control empiezan a tener una
conversación informan las emergencias
la torre de control le dice al capitán
sully por favor trate o haga el giro
para retornar a la pista de aterrizaje
el capitán sully empieza a hacer sus
análisis se toma su tiempo y le dice a
la torre de control
voy a aterrizar en el lago ok son la
torre de control le dice no entiendo por
favor
explícame nuevamente capitán sully el
capitán sully le dice voy a aterrizar en
el lago hawkes pierden comunicación en
ese momento el capitán sully y avisa a
la tripulación y les avisa en dos
ocasiones tripulación prepárense porque
vamos a colisionar tripulación
prepárense porque vamos a colisionar
en esos eventos lo que hace la
tripulación es recoger su cabeza tomar
una posición inclinar la hacia los pies
pero en esos instantes que me imagino
que son instantes muy complejos los
pasajeros se empiezan a enviar sus
whatsapp sus mensajes avisar a sus
familias que pues que van a chocar y que
realmente no sabe qué va a pasar con el
avión
el capitán realiza todas las maniobras y
las operaciones para poder acuatizar el
avión en el lago hobson al cabo de unos
segundos
efectivamente el avión puede aterrizar
en el lago hoxton sin ningún problema
salvando la vida de 115 pasajeros y toda
su tripulación
en el fin en el film el capitán
básicamente argumentaba que en ningún
momento estaba preparado para afrontar
una situación de este calibre durante
sus 48 años de servicio
le correspondió resolver y tomar una
decisión en 280 segundos
en 280 segundos básicamente tuvo que
tomar una decisión demasiado pronto para
poder salvar la vida de 115 personas sin
ningún problema
como esté hecho para significar algo muy
personal
con mis 20 años en la institución
bien vividos afortunadamente
ya en esos grados prematuros
de subteniente trabajaba en la estación
de policía de fusagasugá
más o menos era un viernes diría yo diez
y media a la noche a cuarenta minutos de
este municipio que era un municipio que
se llama vasca vasca es un municipio
ubicado a 45 minutos 40 minutos de
fusagasugá y informan
el radiooperador que se encontraba de
servicio en esta estación que la
estación está siendo atacada por un
grupo guerrillero
perdemos comunicación con la estación
estando hoy en fusagasugá perdemos
comunicación
desafortunadamente quedamos sin más
información y al cabo de unos minutos
diría yo que unos 15 minutos el
radiooperador vuelve y nos informa nos
comunica que el comandante de la
estación estaba gravemente herido
pues empezamos a mirar qué hacemos qué
hacemos nosotros estando a 45 minutos
cómo podemos ayudar a estos compañeros a
estos policías de nuestra institución
que están pasando por un momento
realmente difícil entonces
lo primero que yo pensé
y decidí es que de alguna manera tenía
que yo llegar a ese municipio y tratar
de salvarle la vida a este comandante de
estación que estaba gravemente herido
entonces pensamos cómo llegamos no
podemos llegar porque la vía era muy
riesgosa porque de alguna manera no
sabíamos con qué se nos iba a afrontar
algo muy parecido a lo que el capitán
sully algo inesperado
pero hago las coordinaciones con la
ambulancia con el equipo médico de
fusagasugá y la idea es ir en la
ambulancia y recoger al señor comandante
de la estación en la estación de policía
pasca
el gran reto para mí fue convencer al
equipo médico de que nos llevara en la
ambulancia a recoger a nuestro
comandante
nos cambiamos de civil no utilizamos el
uniforme porque estábamos embarcando en
una ambulancia procedemos a darle una
información muy general a ese equipo
médico para que nos permitiera el
desplazamiento y poder llegar a ese
sitio no sabíamos las circunstancias que
estaba pasando cómo se encontraba
nuestro policía
arrancamos en la ambulancia nos subimos
a la ambulancia subí con otro policía y
vamos en uniforme de íbamos de civil
llegamos básicamente como los 40 minutos
a vasca
realmente el pueblo está totalmente
desolado se escuchaban algunos disparos
sobre la parte alta de la estación y
pudimos ingresar a la estación
rápidamente tomó contacto con él
un policía que se encontraba en una de
las garitas me orienta donde estaba el
policía herido recogemos al policía
rápidamente lo embarcamos a la
ambulancia y
sucede algo que realmente pues no
esperaba y no contábamos con eso
la doctora que nos acompañaba en la
cabina de la ambulancia
por la situación que se presentaba por
la complejidad del entorno por ver las
circunstancias en que se encontraba en
este este policía no la culpo
entra en una situación que no puede
realizar el procedimiento médico
producto de esto pues trato de tomar
comunicación con ella le digo doctora y
tenemos que atender a nuestro compañero
entiendo la situación en que se
encuentra la doctora y la doctora
empieza a comunicarse y me da
instrucciones para que pueda realmente
realizar algunos procedimientos para
atender prehospitalaria mente a nuestro
policía me dice que tengo que hacer le
suministró algunos medicamentos empiezo
a suministrarle líquidos y tratamos de
establecer
la vida de este policía a los 25 minutos
porque esto fue algo muy rápido llegamos
afortunadamente
gracias adiós al hospital san rafael de
fusagasugá y logramos salvarle la vida a
nuestro policía
este hecho para mí fue muy significativo
institucional y personalmente realmente
nunca calculaba nunca pensaba que
estaría atendiendo médicamente a un
policía frente a una situación
totalmente difícil y que colocaba en
riesgo su humanidad así como el capitán
sully yo nunca pensé ni nunca
estuve preparado para afrontar una
situación de esta pero pienso que esos
son los grandes retos que nos pone la
vida esos son los grandes circunstancias
y los grandes obstáculos que nosotros
debemos afrontar y en ese sentido yo y
gracias a mi institución policial mi
institución policial me ha dado las
bases me ha dado los argumentos y me ha
dado el conocimiento que para mí es el
elemento más importante para haber
tomado esa decisión muchas gracias